so you think that we will be okay
we will feel satisfied with the way you
have decided to end
the season i i'm
currently satisfied so i hope that other
people will be
you will not be able to please everybody
but um i'm happy yeah
i love insecure so much i talked to all
my the friends that i grew up with in
rural missouri
they all happen to be white so i've been
talking about now watching
and so my girlfriend was saying like
when the pandemic is over i want to come
visit
and you know i love issa someone can we
go to inglewood i'm like okay
oh my god now she's in there but i
in a way that has to make you feel good
because i'm sure you hear that like
people now they're like i want to see
very easily i want to go to inglewood
it's crazy i love it for the businesses
so this is lamar park
and it's like black everything you know
there's so many black businesses that we
support on the show that i
are just my favorite places to be so to
know that they're on the map in a new
way and that
i know that people are coming to go
visit those places is cool like
people have cussed me out because they
said oh i went to worldwide tacos and it
took four hours and i was like
we put that in the show
we worked you but then even to see i get
tagged
at least three times a day and people
who go to visit the dunes
apartments yeah and these said the
character easton
doesn't even live there anymore lawrence
doesn't live in there anymore but
they're taking a picture next to it like
it's the hollywood sign and i'm so
flattered by that but i
know the residents are hot all of this
sounds bad
but it's actually really good it's good
vibes though by the way
you know i'm not okay with this that is
ending i'm not i'm really not
he's made things clear to me really not
i don't know why we have to be enemies
we don't
we don't you know don't you like endings
to your stories
no i actually am that person who goes on
and on and drones on and on
and who by like likes the plot twist and
just when i thought it was about to eat
so you're the audience for that i've
always wondered who wants this and the
answer is you it's michelle
okay good me and i know that that for
you
it was right and you felt like it was
good
but do you wrestle with that sometimes
because you know like your fan base i'm
sure you've been hearing from people
like
why yeah but i think that that's a good
thing
like i i want to be
you know i always say i never want to
overstay my welcome
and uh from like the
shows that mean the most to me like i
just i wanted a little bit more or you
know i was satisfied with the ending
okay so you don't look at it like you're
breaking our hearts you're well
i hope not no looking at our backs
gently is that what you're doing
it'll still be there for re-watch but
how have you guys because i know you're
shooting
like how is covin and the protocols you
have to do was it a struggle did you all
just fall back in
it's a struggle it was and still is a
struggle
i hate it so much i i feel so thankful
that we're able to work and we're
actually
able to shoot this season because you
know we had a lot of false starts
we were supposed to be shooting way back
in september and that just didn't happen
obviously in la as you know we've been
the epicenter
um and so even just coming out of that
was a challenge
but it's like when people ask of the
season shooting the season is
bittersweet
i say it's mostly sweet and the only
bitter part is the fact that these
code that covet is in place because it
just doesn't allow us to fully
immerse ourselves in the experience and
each other
and you know properly saying goodbye um
and it sucks to go out like that during
this but
things feel a little bit more optimistic
i'm i'm so ready to just
kick it with other vaccinated people and
celebrate like we're supposed to
yeah so so you think that we will be
okay we will feel satisfied with the way
you have decided to end the season
the way this question was asked
um i i'm currently satisfied so i hope
that other people will be you will not
be able to please
everybody but um i'm happy
yeah and do we pick up where we just
left off no time really passed
for this next season you gotta watch to
find out
i'm trying nobody like i would pick
yvonne she's like won't even respond no
[Laughter]
friends yes good job we all learn from
season one season one i have to hit j
and evan and be like really
y'all just go on spot but yes great
is there a chance that there could be
spin-offs
from any of the characters
is there a chance there's a chance for
everything
okay i'ma hold on to that little nugget
you're not saying that it will happen
but then
it could there's a chance
for everything there's pressure because
we're ending a show
but i just i love what we've been able
to do
it was announced that you've got a great
new deal with hbo max
and you're doing so much how do you feel
now stepping into this
new chapter and this new creative space
extremely excited like all the things
that we're working on
you know i have my own ideas but what
really excites me is working with other
creators collaborating with other people
being fans of their work and seeing what
they
they have cooking up is just
you know i'm over the moon right now
with the potential
and um there are a couple of shows that
we
are in the edit process for right now
that i'm just like oh man i can't wait
to people
for people to see this and to experience
this so it's so cool to have a
playground
and at this point i'm just making the
stuff that i want to see like what do i
want to watch on a sunday what what
what's my move for
like this particular movie like what are
the kind of movies that i miss that i
want to see on screen like what
you know are stories that haven't been
told that i'm craving and it feels so
good
to be able to have the trust of you know
warner and hbo they spell family
and their properties to to give us free
reign like that it's
it's cool
no no no cause this is when i first fell
in love with you
no no and because it's the 10th
anniversary of the web series i decided
to re-read
this book that made me fall deep in love
with you before i even like
really fell in love with you thank you
so so much
i've had this book for years and when i
saw that it was the 10th anniversary i
said i'm going to reread this book
it's so crazy because you know with with
tv shows and stuff like that like
i could re-watch them like even on for
black girl during the 10th anniversary i
got to re-watch it i have never
looked at that book since i wrote it up
really
because i'm not going to read what i
look like going back and so there's
stuff that
yeah i just honestly don't remember
what's in it outside of things that i've
already done
now listen but it is the 10th
anniversary and i wonder
10 years since the web series of the
misadventures of the awkward black girl
began
what do you tell this girl 10 years
later what do you tell her
10 years it doesn't feel like 10 years
it still feels like i still am that girl
so i guess i tell her
chill like it gets better like all
all the mistakes that you're making
right now as long as you learn from them
uh you'll get better you'll be okay
um so yeah that's all i have to say
thank you but you'll stay awkward sorry
we are the unseen creators i love
this life unseen project with life water
this really spoke to me so i can only
imagine how it spoke to you because i
feel like
you're such a culture creator and you
know you had to be seen
in some way in order to blossom the way
you have
man you said it yeah as a as a creative
early on
i remember that feeling of just like if
someone if
the right person just sees my work if
i'm on the right platform then i feel
like
i can do what i'm supposed to do and
what i know i can do
and so with this the opportunity to
partner with lifewire on this campaign
just felt like
it was speaking my language you know
they were putting their money where
their mouth is in terms of
featuring the the work of artists on you
know
their their 20 artists on their bottle
collection it's the largest bottle
collections they've ever done so if
you're in a grocery store or wherever
you're going to see the work of these
artists which is such
like that is half the battle to spark
people's interest and curiosity
in addition to also just doing the work
to commission a study
to show like in fashion music film
visual
arts where do we need to do better just
in terms of representation where are we
falling short
and then commissioning not just shining
a light but also paying these artists
for their work
um and you know they're also doing a
contest to find
five more to to spotlight and
you know i have the opportunity to
mentor those those five other artists so
it just really
is completely speaking my language and
my mission and i'm so excited to have
discovered
um so many people that i admire and
hope to work with in the future we
talked about the fact that you're
getting to mentor so is that just part
of it really
that pay it forward spirit that you're
able to do yeah
i mean it really just comes down to
making sure that
it's more than just
like yeah it is more than a seat at the
table it's listening
it's making sure that you have a
permanent spot and
it's also about encouraging these
artists to also ultimately pay it
forward
there's a commitment on my part to make
sure that
they'll continue to work in the various
industries
so there you know they're going to be
people at home saying all right how can
i
get involved how can i enter what can i
do yes
um submit your work with the hashtag
life unseen
contest and you can get that opportunity
to get ten thousand dollars
and to be selected one of the five
selected um and as i said i'll be
mentoring you you'll have the support of
life water
and it's just yeah hopefully it'll make
the difference
that you need i know for me ten thousand
dollars at the time that i needed it was
more money than i had ever seen at once
um so um i can only imagine
what i could do with that money at the
time and hopefully
it'll it'll help someone to get to the
next level that they need to
when you're trying to mentor is the
first question usually like
how did you come up with the idea of
insecure or how did you sell
the idea of insecure like do people is
that usually like one of the first
questions you get
it is it's mostly like how do you start
like where do you
where do you start like what can i it
comes down to like how can i get my
stuff seen
and uh that is the essential question
because a lot of the times people have
done
the work but it's just like where do i
take my work like you know one of the
biggest conundrums
uh specifically in my industry is like
needing an agent or a manager right and
it's like sometimes an agent or manager
won't
see you unless you have your work out
there already and
sometimes getting your work out there
costs money it does
no matter if it's five dollars or a
thousand or ten it
costs money um to make things
nothing's just completely free unless
you're
you're it's a one-off or something like
that to be but to be consistent
costs and some people don't have that
you can't underestimate that
it is easier and they're more resources
but sometimes
it's not enough to just write a script
and hope that it gets out there
your work needs to have some sort of
platform and that's usually when it gets
the attention for a presentation and
once you get representation it does get
a bit easier to have someone
speak on your behalf you